Melanie is in New York hi Melanie
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey
thank you think Nicole sure what's up
I'm currently on baby said sue finally
others that paid off all my credit cards
and it could that's where my credit
cards form right up thank you I do still
on my car I have a jeep about 22 grand
um the Jeep will be over in October of
2022 and I want to do her best opinion
on whether if I should aggressively
snowballing and okay so I want to get
rid of this car so I wanted to get
another car but my options were either
to snowball bids and then go into
another painting in time you cannot for
by the time October 2022 I can pay off
this color and purchase a brand-new car
with also doing maybe certain number
three and having like three is six
months okay well we don't recommend
people buy a brand new car unless they
have a million dollar or more net worth
because a brand new car loses 60 to 70
percent of its value in the first four
years so we want you to buy one two
three year old car until you've got at
least a million dollars in your nest egg
okay but other than that part of it what
what uh what is your household income
all right now I'm with my father right
now you are alright I'm with my father
you work for your father no no I'm with
my father I live with my father you
don't have an income
oh my income my income yes sixty-five
thousand okay all right cool alright and
so you're wanting to trade cars what you
would do is you can call the whoever
holds the fleece on the Jeep and ask
them for the early buyout amount that's
your payoff if you want to pay it off
today okay then you can compare that to
the value of the Jeep and that'll tell
you how far upside down are in the
oh you are okay and so if we find out
that the early buyout is twenty thousand
dollars and the value of the Jeep is
seventeen thousand that means you're
three thousand in the hole that makes
sense yeah okay
so if you were to trade cars down to get
out of debt not up but down lesser
amount of car then that three thousand
dollar hole that you're in would be
added to the new loan and then you would
get in the business of paying that off
as quickly as you can
you cannot prepay a lease
unless you pay the full amount and so if
that if that early buyout is 20,000 you
need $20,000 in your hand to prepay it
because that buys the title out and
everything not just runs the thing up to
October of 2022
that's just your that's just your rental
payments that run until then at the in
October of 2022 if you're going to buy
the car there's a residual value at the
end of the lease that they're gonna
charge you to buy the car at the end the
lease you know that right no okay so at
the end of the leisure they're going to
turn the car in or there's a value on
your lease if you pull it out and look
at it called the residual value that
tells you what you could buy the car for
at the end of the lease after you've
leased it all these years because you're
just rent you're just renting the car is
what you're doing and so you know yes I
think I probably would trade down find
out what your early buyout is and buy a
car compare it to the value you can go
on KBB Kelley Blue Book calm and get the
value the value versus the early buyout
again tells you how far upside-down you
are and then that'll tell you what
you've got to move to another loan now
if you go get another loan get a lesser
loan move down in car and then start pay
if you take a loan rather than a fleece
that's something you can pay off early
and you can start chunking on it hard
and since you don't have any expenses
you're living with that but you make 65
boom you can hit this thing really
really hard and be out of whatever you
move down to very very quickly
or you can just save up the $20,000 if
that's the amount I'm making that number
up might not be that far off but I'm
making it up find out what that early
buyout is and you just write them a
check and then you own the Jeep free and
clear either one but in a sense you'd be
paying extra on a debt but with the
lease you just throw it all into savings
until you had enough to knock it out in
one check because they will not accept
extra payments on the principle because
it's not because you're renting the car